bonjour ici c'est steve kaufmann je vais
faire un vidéo en français parce que
j'ai reçu à une question de questions a
fait d'une personne en france
mathilde qui me demandent d'abord pour
pourquoi est ce qu'il y a davantage
d'hommes polyglotte sur youtube que de
femmes et deuxièmement est ce qu'il y a
une limite au nombre de langues que le
cerveau le cerveau peut apprendre
je vais donc répondre à ces deux
questions là et je vais aussi faire un
petit commentaire sur un livre que je
viens de commencer à lire
voilà réveille-toi jules ferry ils sont
devenus fous
bon pourquoi est ce que il semble avoir
davantage de domme polyglotte sur
youtube que de femmes
je crois que c'est un phénomène lié au
fait que les femmes sont moins portés à
se montrer sur l'internet en général
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a davantage
d'hommes sur youtube femmes et est parmi
les raisons c'est que souvent si les
femmes présentent leurs photos vidéos
sur youtube il ya des des commentaires
et cetera d'hommes qui sont moins
agréable il ya toutes sortes de
personnes sur internet et je crois que
les femmes et peut-être avec raison son
teint plus un peu plus timide à cet
égard là c'est ça serait la seule région
parce que je crois qu'il ya sûrement
autant de femmes
polyglotte kodom polyglotte deuxième
question est ce qu'il y a une limite au
nombre de langues que le cerveau peut
apprendre peu d'apprendre je ne crois
pas la limite c'est limité par le temps
parce que bon il faut y mettre du temps
ça prend du temps d'apprendre des
langues
et une fois qu'on a appris les landes
bon on aime bien on aimerait bien les
utiliser moi j'ai onze langues
oh je peux lire et j'essaie de lire un
roman portugais en espagnol en français
et en japonais
c'est très difficile de non seulement
fin d'abord pour les maintenir
mais aussi parce que j'aime donc plus on
a de jouer moins de temps pour jouer
avec chacun de ses jouets donc c'est ça
la limite c'est que j'aime j'aime mes
langues
j'aime jouir de ces langues là et plus
j'ai deux langues moins de temps j'ai
pour chaque langue
c'est la seule limite que je vois parce
que il y à des personnes bien connues
qui ont pu maîtriser 40 ou 50 ans mais
comment trouver le temps pour lire en 50
langues parlées avec des personnes des
natifs de ces gens atteints de ces
langues là etc
c'est la seule limite que je vois est
finalement bon en ce qui concerne le
livre sur l'éducation en france j'ai
trouvé à voilà une citation que le
trouve très intéressant et je veux
seulement le mentionner ici
jules ferry le fondateur de l'école
laïque gratuite et obligatoire avait
dire à la fin du 19e siècle qu'il
s'agissait dans les écoles il ne s'agit
pas d'embrasser tout ce qu'il est
possible de savoir mais de bien
apprendre ce qu'il n'est pas permis
d'ignorer et enfin les gens qui ont
écrit ce livre enfin emmanuel
davidenkoff l'écrivain celui qui a
détruit le leem il
il dit que maintenant les écoles il
essaie de trop trop enseigner et
comme s'il fallait que les élèves
apprennent tout ce qu'il est possible de
savoir et le système est incapable de
s'assurer que les élèves apprennent bien
ce qui n'est pas permis d'ignorer
on est tous tous enfin on connaît les
difficultés qu'ont beaucoup de personnes
dans la lecture dans des choses de base
comme ça et c'est surtout ce que je vois
dans l'enseignement des langues et
surtout surtout ici au canada ou dans le
système anglophone on enseigne beaucoup
de règles de grammaire le subjonctif et
ne sais pas quoi
et même je sais que dans le dans la
fonction publique où il ya une prime
pour le bilinguisme pour obtenir ce prix
mais il faut démontrer qu'on maîtrise le
subjonctif par exemple étant donné que
la majorité des élèves de système
anglophone après 10 ans ou 12 ans
d'apprentissage du français ne savent
même pas parler la langue
elles ne comprennent pas la langue à
quoi ça sert de données des tests dans
le subjonctif et c'est exactement la
même chose et par les systèmes scolaires
mais pour les pour la fonction publique
où la plupart des arbres phone ne savent
pas parler anglais et français pendant
un pardon ne peuvent pas utiliser le
français dans leur travail
à quoi ça sert d'aller tester dans le
subjonctif donc j'ai hâte de lire tout
ce bouquin mais souvent j'ai
l'impression que les les bons conseils
de jules ferry sont un peu laissés à
côté dans l'enseignement public que ce
soit en france ou au canada et surtout
quand il s'agit de l'apprentissage
l'enseignement des langues
merci beaucoup